what I want to do in this video is
explore the idea of a unit vector and a
unit vector is just a vector that goes
in a particular direction that has a
magnitude that has a magnitude of 1 so
let's take an example let's say that I
have the vector let's say the vector a
and it in the horizontal direction for
every three that it moves in the
vertical direction it moves up four it
moves up four so what else do we know
about this well we could figure out a
magnetic the of vector a well this would
just be the length of it so let's let's
try to visualize a so for every three
that we go in the horizontal direction
we're going to go four in the vertical
direction we're going to go four in the
vertical direction and so vector a would
look something like this would look
something like would look like that that
is vector vector a so what's its
magnitude well the magnitude is just the
length of this vector right over here
and we could use the Pythagorean theorem
to figure out that to figure this out
this length is going to be the square
root of the sum of the squares of the
other two sides so this is just the
hypotenuse of this right triangle so
this is going to be 3 squared plus 4
squared plus 4 squared or this is going
to be the square root of 9 plus 16
square root of 25 square root of 25 or
it's going to be equal to 5 and you
might have just recognize that this
would be a 3 4 5 right triangle so the
length of this side right over here is 5
so I could say the magnitude of a is
equal to 5 so this is clearly not a unit
vector it has a length it has a
magnitude of something other than 1 but
let's say we wanted to construct a unit
vector that has the same direction as a
but has a length of only 1 so another
way of thinking about it
say we wanted to figure out a vector
that goes in the exact same direction
but it has one-fifth the magnitude it
only has a magnitude of one so what
could we do well if we scale everything
down by a fifth if we were to multiply
each of these I guess you could say
components of our vector a by a fifth or
another way of thinking but if we divide
each of these by the magnitude of a then
we could construct this unit vector and
I'm going to call that unit vector I'll
call it a but instead of putting a
instead of putting an arrow on top I'm
going to put I'm going to put actually
let's just to not confuse ourselves
let's call it U for a unit vector and to
also make it clear it's a unit vector
and not just a normal vector I'm going
to put this little hat so instead of
this little arrow when you put this hat
this denotes that you're dealing with a
unit vector a vector with magnitude of 1
so the unit vector could we could write
it down is it's going to be equal to
it's going to be equal to each of these
components for a we just divide by the
magnitude of a we just divide by the
magnitude of a so this 3 in the
horizontal direction 4 in the vertical
direction once again and just divided by
the magnitude magnitude of our vector
and so this is going to be equal to the
magnitude we already figured out is 5 so
it's going to be 3/5 3/5 in the
horizontal direction and 4/5 4/5 in the
vertical direction and you can verify
this is going to have one way to think
about the ratio between these two
numbers is the exact same thing as the
ratio up here so we're going in the same
direction but the magnitude here is now
going to be equal to 1 and you can
verify that let's do that so what's the
magnitude now of our unit vector let me
write that hat a little bit that hat got
a little crooked what's the magnitude of
unit vector U well it's going to be the
square root of the sum of the squares of
these two components so it's going to be
the square of three-fifths is 9 over 25
9 over 25 plus the square of 4/5
is 16 over 25 over 25 and what's that
going to be well 9 plus 16 is 25 so it's
going to be the square root of 25 so
that plus that is 25 25 over 25 which is
just going to be equal to the square
root or I guess we're taking the
principal root the positive square root
of 1 which is just equal to 1 which is
exactly what we wanted it goes in the
same direction
but magnitude is 1 and that's why it's a
unit vector